el mundo avanza con los ojos cerrados
hacia la catástrofe así lo alarmó este
lunes el secretario general de naciones
unidas antonio guterres durante una
conferencia sobre desarrollo sostenible
organizada por la revista británica the
economist
guterres señaló que la prisa por usar
combustibles fósiles y abandonar la
dependencia del gas y petróleo rusos es
una locura la guerra en ucrania también
muestra como la adicción global a los
combustibles fósiles está poniendo la
seguridad energética y toda la economía
global a merced de la geopolítica todos
los países necesitan hacer una
transición rápida y controlada a la
energía renovable la invasión rusa
ucrania pone en jaque los objetivos
climáticos de parís y de la reciente con
26 para cortar los suministros rusos
como sanción por los ataques
indiscriminados en el país vecino muchas
naciones están recurriendo al carbón oa
las importaciones de gas natural liquado
como alternativas lo que tendrá
consecuencias devastadoras a nivel
climático según el líder de la onu
nuestros objetivos fueron alcanzados por
todas las partes a la luz de las pruebas
científicas para reducir las emisiones
de gases de efecto
en un 45 por ciento para 2030 y lograr
la neutralidad de carbono para 2050 para
conseguirlo necesitamos contribuciones
determinadas a nivel nacional más
ambiciosas y sus estrategias a largo
plazo por parte de los gobiernos
nacionales
según naciones unidas se tendrá que
reducir en un 45 por ciento las
emisiones de carbono de aquí a 2030 para
que el umbral de 15 grados celsius no
sea superado un futuro todavía lejano